all right so the flash feels like
somewhat of a celebration of DC's long
and Rich history on the big and small
screen you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
the movie of course brings back both zot
and Michael Keaton's Batman but beyond
that there's also a number of different
cameos that call back to time has gone
by throughout this video we're gonna be
going through them all and explaining
what happened with some of the
characters and the actors attached to
them heavy spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
film then I highly recommend that you
check out now if you enjoy the video
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day with that out of the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the Flash
you're strapped to your parachutes and
where's yours
wow
the film brings back the Justice League
for its opening scene and when Barry
tries to reform the team in 2013 he runs
into some snacks due to when this is set
they haven't been formed yet but we do
get an odd to members of the group and
what they're up to at the time Ray
fish's Victor Stone is shown to still be
playing college football and we of
course saw clips of this and Zack
Snyder's Justice League as we learn in
the film some things in the past are
changed though and this includes Jason
momoa's Aquaman Arthur curry in this
timeline his dad never met Atlanta and
this Aquaman never got to be born the
dog from the movie returned so with a
vein called Arthur and we get Tamira
Morrison once more playing his father
bayora of course returns with sword
alongside the Kryptonian Giant and we
also get a glimpse at GI Courtney in the
Chrono Bowl Suicide Squad Show The Flash
was the one who captured here man this
is obviously a clear reference to that
scene from the opening of that movie now
the film actually features several
different cameos from Superman actors
from over the years Henry cavill's
versions referenced on a news report and
he appears in CGI during the Jay
Courtney scene in addition to this the
Chrono Bowl scenes filled with quite a
lot of them and for the next part of the
video I want to discuss these in depth
one of these is George Reeves who
appears in black and white like his
classic TV show starring in The
Adventures of Superman this ran from
1952 all the way up to 1956.
[Music]
initially reluctant to take the role
Reeves worried that not many people
would see his work due to it being on
television but the show was a big
success at the time of its release now
if you've ever seen the movie
Unbreakable then you might remember the
scene in which David Anderson Joseph
points a gun at his dad because he
believes that the bullets are just gonna
bounce off him this is something that
was actually inspired by a real life
story involving Reeves who at a
convention had a gun pulled on him by a
kid like done in the movie Reeves
managed to talk him out of it and he did
this by saying that he was right and
that the bullets would just bounce off
him however they would go on to then hit
others in the crowd and innocence would
be hurt so just put the gun down kid now
Reeves made a major name for himself but
this also came with more downsides as
after its end he was unable to find her
the work the only roles Reeves ever got
offered were playing soups and at the
age of 45 he felt like he was getting
too old to do the whole capes and tights
thing feeling like a failure he
descended into depression and he ended
up dying during a party which which was
being held at his home filled with
Hollywood hot shots at the time Reeves
ended up going upstairs looking
depressed and one unlucky even remarked
that he looked like he was going to
shoot himself which eerily came true
after hearing a gunshot this person
apparently said I Told You So and Reeves
was sadly found dead in his bedroom with
no note being left since then there have
been conspiracy theories around his
passing with his mysterious death being
at the center of several documentaries
going over whether it was as simple as
it seemed nothing's ever been proved
conclusively and it's a sad Legacy for
the actor which is of course murdered in
Christopher Reeve who too appears in the
film still sitting up top as my favorite
Superman I actually rewatched all of his
movies recently due to the 4K special
edition steelbook set that just got
released the guy just has something
about him and I must admit a tear up at
the end when I see him smiling as he
flies off on the camera
foreign
[Applause]
some of these made me feel a bit weird
in the cinema because of how poorly the
CGI had been done on them and I feel
like this is gonna be the prime example
another term PS2 Graphics gets banded
around a lot but I think when you're
doing digital necromancy that you need
to make sure it's Flawless as it can
come across like you're using a dead guy
just to get your movie Cameo points I
think Harold Ramis was a great example
of how to do it right and not only did
they clearly put a lot of money into
making sure it looked real but they also
built the film up as a tribute to him
I've seen this Christopher Reeves thing
being described as a CGI puppet and when
Brandon Routh canonically is the same
character then there are other ways to
Tastefully go about it anyway I don't
want to bug the whole video down as this
is just kind of going over who appears
in the movie how about I do think it's
worth discussing so if you agree or
disagree then let me know below now as
I'm sure many of you know Reeve ended up
falling from his horse in 1990 5 which
sadly left him paralyzed from the neck
down having difficulty moving and
breathing this didn't stop him though
and Reed became a voice at sparka in
favor of stem cell research and trying
to Aid people with disabilities sadly he
passed away in 2004 after slipping into
a coma but the actors still remembered
finally almost 20 years later due to all
the incredible work he did now one
person that you might also be surprised
to see playing Superman is who is he
your Nick
[Music]
yeah that's right Nicholas Cage actually
pops up in the film as an alternate
version of Superman that has a pretty
wild backstory to it in case you don't
know Tim Burton actually got asked to
revive the character after his success
on the first two Batman films and
Superman lives was then put into
production had a tumultuous time I don't
know why I use it had a tumultuous time
in production and and this was all
documented in the incredible film The
Death of Superman lives they just wanted
us to go crazy they just said just drama
monsters
now when you think about it if somebody
was like would you like to see a Nick H
Superman movie I'd be like and yes take
all my money because I want to see what
that looks like this recounts all the
original plans they had stories of what
was going on in the script and some
Hilarious Moments where Kevin Smith
talks about how mentals some of the
ideas are on the film were at the center
of it was cage and they spent months
alone just building his suit this was
supposed to be thriving with electricity
and it looks pretty cool when you see
the behind the scenes stuff now in case
you don't know Nicholas Cage is actually
a mega mega mega Superman fan and cage
actually named his son Khalil yep not
lying and because of this I always felt
kind of bad that the chance to play his
dream role was taken away from him he
got so close to it however it never
materialized so to me it's really nice
for him to at least get some
acknowledgment with his scene and I I
was happy to see him here now Beyond
there being all these several Superman
connections we also get one referencing
Supergirl with Sasha Kaye being a major
part of the film we of course have to
have another one of her previous
live-action versions and we get this in
the form of Helen Slater
Helen Slater as Supergirl
Adventure runs in the family
all the way back in 1984 Slater played
Supergirl which was supposed to tie in
with the Christopher reverse however his
initially slated Cameo was scrapped
because he probably read this script and
what we got was a news report saying
that he'd left Earth on a peacekeeping
mission this explained why he wasn't in
the movie and the film itself has kind
of been brushed to the side to the point
that it's not really brought up all that
much she actually appears in the same
scene alongside Reeves showing that
their iterations did eventually meet up
and join forces now one thing that is
still in the pop cultures like guys
though is the CW's version of The Flash
unfortunately Grand Gustin doesn't show
up in the film which I felt was kind of
a disservice as the guys put in so many
as the character Gran has played him
since 2014 and though his and Ezra's
version meant crisis it would have been
nice to see him coming here however who
we get is Teddy Sears and he's playing
none other than Jay Garrick Jay Garrick
was the original flash in the comics and
they had Teddy playing this Golden Age
character in The CWC series now not to
get too spoilery on what happens in The
Flash but yeah this Cameo leaked and in
the build up to it I was hoping there'd
be a little joke about how it seemed
like he was a nice guy honestly I kind
of feel like John Wesley's ship should
have been in the role instead as he
played Jay Garrick in The Flash show and
was also a version of Barry Allen in the
90s TV series I read on Twitter so take
this with a pinch of salt but I read
that someone just Googled Jay Galaxy W
to insert the quick Cameo here and that
they put him in instead of Wesley ship
which could be the case now it might
also be the fact that they don't want
people to have things ruined as there is
a big twist involving them which I have
just spoiled to be fair but hey the
channel the channel is called heavy
spoilers now either way Jay really set
the groundwork for Barry and there's
been multiple different characters
you've taken over the mantle including
Wally West on top along with Michael
Keaton's Batman we also get some other
iterations of The Dark Knight and this
includes Adam West's version Adam West
is the one that I think a lot of people
my age grew up on and because as though
we had the Keaton version parents might
not have let their kids watch it I was
fine because my parents just let me
watch things like the thing when I was
four years old but I know a lot had to
resort to just watching reruns of Adam
West and Bert Ward's Robin was of course
camp and over the top but at the time a
lot less young kids didn't really get
that it was supposed to be a joke and I
took everything deadly serious
now what normally happens with a lot of
Batman takes is that the actors are
popular when they're in the roll then
they drop out a new one comes in and
everyone says they're so much better and
that older actor gets hated on this
happened when Keaton took over West when
Bale took Harbor from Clooney and so on
and so forth all the audiences
eventually come back around on these
guys though and normally a couple of
decades later they get given their
flowers this happened in the case of
West 2 with a lot of people now
celebrating his campy comedic version
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb the internet has really allowed
aspects of that show to become a meme
and since then they made comic book runs
of Batman 66 along with a lot of
animated movies we of course also have
Ben Affleck appearing in the film and
it's nice that there's all these
versions of Batman showing up in the
movie now that takes us into the major
Cameo that comes at the end of the film
and the person I'm talking about is
George Clooney the film ends with Barry
traveling into his universe and I think
he's had a sort of Revival too when it
comes to health bands feel about him
sure Batman and Robin was but I
think a lot of people can now just view
that as being a camp comedy that you
don't have to take too seriously I have
done a full breakdown on the scene as
well and what it could mean for the
future which I will link at the end of
the video in case you want to check it
out anyway some miscellaneous
appearances by other actors are gal
gadots Wonder Woman and she appears at
the start of the movie Jason momoa's
Aquaman also drops in for the
post-credits scene and you also have
Annie machete showing up at one point in
the film lastly is also nikolaj Costa
Waldo who in the ends in a pretty
non-consequential role his appearance
actually leaked a couple of years back
and people wrongly assumed that he'd
play the reverse flash in the film
however that was a lie and I
think that it was just brought in
because the Pair worked together on the
film Mama anyway that's all the cameos I
could spot in the movie that have
meaning to them and I hope you've
enjoyed going to this breakdown
obviously there are some things to talk
about Beyond just the people who pop up
as well so if you have your thoughts on
bringing dead actors back to life and
whether this was done Tastefully or not
then comment down below if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get early access to videos every week
you also have our merch store over at
xeronation.com and this sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more we
just launched a secret Invasion slash
Pulp Fiction in spy t-shirt so if you
want to head over there after this and
help us out then the links in the
description now if you want some Elves
to watch we've got that video on screen
right now going over what happens at the
end of the movie huge thank you for
sitting until the end of the breakdown
I've been host Paul as always I hope
that you enjoy the rest of your bloody
brilliant week by the way thanks for
clicking this you take ace off and I'll
see you next time peace